[Music]
sean worsley
a veteran sentenced to five years in
prison in alabama for using medicinal
marijuana
he'd been legally prescribed to treat a
traumatic brain injury
fair wayne bryant 63 years old
sentenced to life in prison for stealing
a pair of hedge clippers because 18
years before he had been convicted of
robbing a taxi driver
khalif browder a 16 year old held in
prison for
three years in new york for allegedly
stealing a backpack
charged but never put on trial beaten by
prison guards and placed in solitary
confinement for two years he attempted
suicide twice in prison still
traumatized he committed suicide at his
mother's home after being released
these are just three drops in a sea of
similar stories all across the united
states
why are these stories so common one of
the ugly truths about our country is
that we lock up a higher percentage of
our people than
any other nation on earth in fact
we imprison more people than any other
country period
we are the biggest prison in the world
we have a significantly larger prison
population
2.1 million people than china a country
with three times
our population why does the united
states lock up
so many of its people more than the
entire population of new mexico
where did this wholesale imprisonment of
huge groups of people
what we call mass incarceration come
from
let's go back a few decades starting in
the 1960s many companies
looking to cut costs moved production
out of big cities like detroit milwaukee
cleveland or simply automated away big
chunks of their workforce
their employees were left jobless and
manufacturing was ripped out of great
cities
that used to be synonymous with industry
after 1970
unemployment for non-college-educated
men soared
especially black people who were just
then entering the middle class
people who could leave the cities mostly
middle class whites
fled to the suburbs a phenomenon we call
white
flight this led to a vicious spiral
cities lost tax revenue
schools lost funding houses lost their
value
local economies collapsed job
opportunities dried up
as urban poverty rose crime rose with it
and the arrival of crack cocaine in the
80s
helped along by u.s foreign policy in
central america
made the problem even worse by the 1970s
and 80s there was a
full-blown social crisis in american
cities
resulting in a steady increase in crime
now american politicians could have
responded one way
they could have confronted the root
causes of crime by reinvesting in
hollowed-out cities
building a healthier cleaner more
prosperous society
but that is not what they did instead
they unleashed a tsunami of
incarceration
they chose to lock up millions of people
rather than accept the type of broad
redistribution
of wealth jobs and power that a real
solution would have demanded
mass incarceration is expensive
but for the well-off it turns out to be
a lot cheaper than actually solving the
problem
so the u.s government decided to combine
the harshest penal state in the world
with the stingiest welfare state this
carceral approach
was also effective politics with white
voters terrified
of rising crime from increasingly
non-white cities
republicans and democrats alike saw a
way to exploit racist
fears and get cheap votes it started
with richard nixon's promise of law and
order in 1968
ronald reagan vowed to get tough on
crime in the 80s
by 1996 a democrat like hillary clinton
was warning of young quote super
predators with quote
no conscience no empathy people who must
be quote
brought to heal over those decades
politicians from both parties and at
all levels passed harsher and harsher
laws feeding the prison system
the war on drugs started in 1971.
cruel mandatory minimum laws came in the
1980s
three strikes laws arrived in the 90s
you could be
put away for life without parole for
stealing a pair of socks if it was your
third offense
tough on crime prosecutors and judges
gained office
across the country huge sums of money
were spent on building new prisons
which housed millions of people as a
result
incarceration rose dramatically 1968
america's prison population was 102 per
100
000 people in line with other developed
countries
by 2005 it had risen sevenfold to 737
per 100 000
the highest in the world even as crime
fell
with murders in new york dropping 90
percent in the 90s
mass incarceration kept on growing why
didn't prison populations fall
once crime started declining it's
because prisons are by no means
only about crime they're also about
keeping the least advantaged people
in line prison has become the place to
warehouse people with mental illnesses
people experiencing homelessness and
people with addictions that the system
is not designed to help
instead of solving these problems we use
prison to disappear the people
who have these problems with this
surging population
prisons are crowded and violent people
in prison are robbed of their humanity
often brutalized by guards and without
real rehabilitation or good options for
re-entry into society
are sometimes turned into the hardened
criminals the system believes them to be
that's why academic evidence suggests
that prisons make people
more likely to engage in criminal
behavior
not less you can't eradicate crime
without eradicating the root causes of
crime
including prison and it was poor and
non-white communities that were the
hardest hit
hurt by de-industrialization and then
criminalized by the state
black men born between 1965 and 1969
have been more likely to go to prison
than to graduate from college
less educated people in general are
victim to this
a white man without a high school degree
has a 25
chance of being imprisoned in his
lifetime a black man without a high
school degree has a 70 percent chance
mass incarceration has done massive harm
to our communities our families our
children
and to the millions of people caught up
in it mass incarceration cannot exist
in a healthy society it is an
intentional
humanitarian disaster a war
by the ruling class on the poor and the
marginalized
mass incarceration is a choice
but it's their choice not ours
this is chase madar professor of law for
the gravel institute
[Music]
so
[Music]
you